JONATHAN VIGLIOTTI, YOSEMITE
NATIONAL PARK.
>>> MANY OF US ARE STILL NERVOUS
ABOUT RETURNING TO NORMAL.
ONE SURVEY FOUND NEARLY 50% OF
AMERICANS ARE ANXIOUS ABOUT
HAVING IN-PERSON INTERACTIONS.
AGAIN, LET'S TALK ABOUT THAT
WITH PSYCHOLOGIST AND CBS NEWS
CONTRIBUTOR LISA DAMOUR.
LISA?
GOOD MORNING.
>> GOOD MORNING.
GOOD TO SEE YOU.
>> SO LISA, WHAT DO YOU SAY TO
PEOPLE WHO MIGHT BE ANXIOUS
ABOUT RETURNING TO SOMEWHAT
NORMAL LIKE LIFE USED TO BE?
>> WHAT I WOULD SAY IS JUST
THINK OF IT AS BEING OUT OF
PRACTICE, RIGHT.
WE USED TO MAKE SMALL TALK WITH
PEOPLE ALL THE TIME.
NOW WE HAVEN'T DONE THAT FOR
ALMOST MORE THAN A YEAR.
AND IT'S LIKE IF YOU HAD BEEN
PRACTICING PIANO EVERY DAY AND
THEN YOU STEPPED AWAY FOR A VERY
LONG TIME.
YOU'LL FEEL UNEASY WHEN YOU SIT
BACK DOWN AT THAT PIANO, BUT
THAT DOESN'T MEAN YOU'RE
STARTING FROM ZERO.
AS SOON AS YOU GET BACK INTO IT,
IT WILL ALL COME BACK.
THE SAME IS TRUE FOR OUR SOCIAL
SKILLS.
THE OTHER THING I WOULD SAY IS
THAT IF YOU'RE FEELING REALLY
NERVOUS, START SMALL.
IF YOU'RE WORRIED ABOUT THINGS
LIKE ORDERING MEALS IN
RESTAURANTS, DON'T START WITH A
THREE-COURSE MEAL.
GO GET YOURSELF A CUP OF COFFEE
SOMEWHERE AND WARM UP.
EASE YOURSELF INTO IT.
>> THAT MAKES A LOT OF SENSE.
SO MANY OF US ARE FEELING
ANXIETY THESE DAYS.
HOW DO -- HOW DOES ANXIETY
AFFECT ALL OF THOSE IN OUR
FAMILY, THOSE AROUND US?
>> WELL, YOU KNOW, WE DO FEEL
ANXIOUS, AND SOMETIMES OUR
ANXIETY CAN FEEL CONTAGIOUS.
SO OUR JOB IS TO TRY TO MANAGE
IT EFFECTIVELY, ESPECIALLY IF WE
HAVE KIDS.
WHAT WE WANT TO MODEL FOR
CHILDREN AND THOSE AROUND US IS
THAT WE CAN HANDLE ANXIETY.
THE GOAL HERE IS NOT TO FEEL
TOTALLY COMFORTABLE.
UNCOMFORTABLE FEELINGS ARE
ABSOLUTELY PART OF LIFE.
THE GOAL IS TO MANAGE THOSE
FEELINGS EFFECTIVELY, TO HAVE
EFFECTIVE WAYS TO COPE WITH
THEM, TO DEAL WITH THE
SITUATIONS IN FRONT OF US, NOT
TO LET THE FEELINGS RUN THE
SHOW.
>> I LIKE WHAT YOU SAID ABOUT
STARTING SMALL, IF YOU'RE GOING
TO GO A RESTAURANT.
DON'T ORDER THREE COURSES, ORDER
ONE.
LISTEN, IF I'M GOING, I WANT ALL
THREE COURSES.
AT LEAST I DID SOMETHING FOR THE
FIRST TIME YESTERDAY -- LAST
NIGHT WENT TO A GROUP DINNER
WITH OTHER PEOPLE.
IT WAS A LITTLE JARRING AT FIRST
BECAUSE YOU SAID THIS MAY CHANGE
THE WAY WE SOCIALIZE.
AND THIS WAS VERY EVIDENT LAST
NIGHT.
YOU SEE PEOPLE YOU HAVEN'T SEEN
IN A WHILE, AND EVERYBODY'S
SAID, ARE YOU VACCINATED, ARE
YOU VACCINATED, OKAY, WE CAN
HUG.
WE WERE TOLD AHEAD OF TIME,
EVERYBODY IN THIS ROOM WILL BE
VACCINATED.
WE WERE ALL TRYING TO NAVIGATE
DO WE HUG, DO WE ELBOW BUMP, DO
WE -- WHAT DO WE DO?
SO YOU SAY IT'S GOING TO CHANGE
THE WAY WE SOCIALIZE.
I CERTAINLY SAW THAT LAST NIGHT.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> WELL, IT MAY MEAN THAT WE
MAINTAIN SMALLER SOCIAL CIRCLE
OR WE SOCIALIZE LESS OFTEN THAN
WE DO IN THE PAST.
AND I KNOW THAT IT CAN FEEL
STRESSFUL TO THINK ABOUT DOING
THINGS DIFFERENTLY NOW THAN WE
USED TO, BUT WHAT WE HAVE TO
REMEMBER IS THAT HUMAN BEINGS
ARE REALLY GOOD AT ADAPTING.
YOU KNOW, IN MARCH, 2020, WE
ADAPTED VERY ABRUPTLY TO LIFE
UNDER THE PANDEMIC.
AND THEN WE GOT ASUS TOMMED TO
IT.
-- ACCUSTOMED TO IT.
WE'LL FIND OUR NEW RHYTHMS
AGAIN.
>> AS YOU POINTED OUT, LISA, A
LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE LINGERING
ANXIETY.
BUT YOU SAY WE SHOULDN'T WAIT
FOR THIS ANXIETY TO GO AWAY.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN?
>> WELL, ANXIETY'S A NORMAL AND
HEALTHY EMOTION.
IT'S JUST PART OF LIFE.
AND WE DON'T WANT IT TO KEEP US
FROM DOING THINGS WE WANT TO DO
LIKE SEEING THE PEOPLE WE CARE
ABOUT.
ONE WAY TO THINK ABOUT IT IS TO
TREAT ANXIETY AS ONE MEMBER OF
YOUR PERSONAL BOARD OF
DIRECTORS.
IT GETS A VOTE IN THE DECISIONS
YOU MAKE, BUT IT'S VERY RARELY
GETTING THE DECIDING VOTE.
>> CAN YOU GIVE TIPS ON HOW TO
DEAL WITH OUR ANXIETY THOSE
DAYS?
>> ABSOLUTELY.
FIRST, IT'S NORMAL AND EXPECTED
TO BE A LITTLE BIT ELEVATED
AFTER WE'VE BEEN AVOIDING FOR SO
>> SOOTHING --
>> THAT'S ONE OF THE TIPS.
HAVE LISA AROUND --
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
WE ALWAYS FEEL BEFORE AFTER
SHE'S BEEN WITH US.
>> CAN YOU BE MY SUPPORT PERSON,
LISA?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I LIKE ANXIETY'S A MEMBER O